INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
So last time, we talked about
quite a few basic commands
in Linux.
And today, I just want to expand
on that a little bit more.
Show you some more advanced
things, not necessarily
that we're going
to do every day,
but you might see me
type or reference.
And I just want you to have
seen it before in some place.
Again, as I said before,
none of this or am I
expecting you to
memorize or store away.
This is stuff that
is easily searchable.
So view this video as an
explainer, not necessarily
a comprehensive guide.
Certainly Google things,
reference things as necessary.
This is not something
I memorize either.
So either way, kind of
jumping back into it.
So notice again that I'm
back in my ec2 instance here.
So I'm just reconnected to
the same one I was on before.
You can easily do that if I
just exit out for a second.
You can rerun the command on
your PowerShell or your terminal
window here.
Just your ssh.
It's still the same pem or the
same key pair that I'm using.
So that SharadsMacbookPro.pem.
And I'm still connecting
to the exact same URL.
So you can see
ubuntu@ec2 whatever,
whatever .compute.amazonaws.com.
So just rerun that and
you'll reconnect to it.
One thing I will note, though,
depending on your network,
you might run into issues.
I just realized this
today when I tried
to reconnect actually to this.
If I was on just the standard
or the guest blue zone network
here on campus or sorry.
The Guest Now, what it's called.
I was not able to do that.
And that's likely because
for security reasons,
they block ssh access when
you're on that network.
That's a whole separate
discussion to get into.
But just note that when
I connected to eduroam,
I was perfectly able to
just reconnect to it.
So if you hit an error where it
says something like Connection
Refused, then you might
be having an issue
with your network connection.
So I would just try
a different network.
Either way, and actually,
I also workaround for that.
You can always use the
ec2 instance connect
that I showed you before where
you just click to Connect 2
when you're on that page.
So workarounds, but that's
something to keep in mind.
So getting back into
it, if you remember,
and I'm going to type
clear here and hit Enter.
Clear just clears out that page.
So if you ever have it
printing out way too far,
it's an easy enough thing
to do to just clear out
the history here.
So that gets us to where
we were last time, where
we had seen how to edit, copy,
remove, move files themselves.
And so now, I just want to talk
a little bit about the hierarchy
of our Linux environment here.
So if you remember, if
I go cd and just slash,
that'll take me to
the root directory.
Remember, the root
directory looked like this.
The root directory is again
the absolute top most directory
in our file system hierarchy.
There is nothing above
the root directory.
Everything else is going
to exist below that.
And all of yours will look
like this or something very,
very similar to this by default.
These are a bunch of things that
are pre-installed or set
up in advance on any kind
of fresh Ubuntu install.
Windows has an equivalent
version of this, as does Mac.
They all have the
core ideas though.
So the home directory, that is
the one we use the most often.
So cd home.
And remember in there
is our user directory.
So cd ubuntu was our actual
user name for this account.
And so this had our
documents folder in it.
But if I go back for a second,
and notice that I can just
directly path myself or give the
absolute path to this location.
If I go back to the
home for a second,
this will always contain all the
personal directories for users.
So if there were multiple
users on this specific machine,
this specific instance.
You would have multiple users
listed here when I run ls.
So that's one thing to note.
Then if we go back up a level,
so back to the root directory,
we have this etc directory.
And that'll just contain all
sorts of system configuration
files.
So a bunch of stuff
that we have no need
to dig into or touch right now.
It's all installed by
default. But it's there
for us to reference.
And again, remember, if I
want to clear out this page,
I'm not looking at a
bunch of junk on here.
I can just type clear.
So that's the etc directory.
If we go back, then we can
look at the var directory.
And this contains all sorts
of variable data files.
So anything that's
changing over time.
So logs, the spool.
This will be stored here.
So if you're ever debugging
things or something says
it's dumping to
your logs directory,
it's going to be
in that var folder.
So it's for files that
change frequently.
And we can go back up a level.
And remember, again,
I'm just keep going back
to this root directory here.
So now, I'm going to go to
this usr or user directory.
This isn't necessarily--
or this isn't
our home directory or our
user account within our home
directory.
This folder is specifically
designed for anything
that you might have installed.
Any user-installed
software and/or libraries.
So it'll have a bin in
here, which will typically
contain executable programs.
And then it'll
have a lib in here,
which will have all your
libraries that you've installed.
So that's all that's in there.
Again, none of this
stuff is really critical
to have a deep understanding of.
But just know that
if you're ever
looking for system-level files,
start from the root directory.
And you'll probably find it.
If you're looking for
your personal files,
then they'll be in your
actual user account.
So another really helpful one.
If you need to
access manual pages.
So like you're curious what
a specific function does
or what it can do,
one way to do that
is to just pull up its manual.
So for example,
here now I'm saying
the command is man for manual.
And the option in
this case, remember
we said it's always
command, option, arguments,
or the argument, in this case.
There's no options used.
Those are usually the
hyphen something else.
The argument used here is ls.
So we're saying we want the
manual page for the listing
function or the listing command.
And you can see this just prints
out all the different options
that we have for the ls command.
So bunch a bunch of
information here.
Then I can back out of that.
Oops.
Man, I need to really
find my commands here.
Forget exactly how to back out.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's right.
I actually need to q.
Let me try this one more time.
There we go.
I was not clicked
into the actual page.
And I also was covering
at the bottom here.
But if you saw there, if I pull
that back up at the very bottom
here, which, again, was
blocked by my laptop here,
it says press q to quit.
So you just tap the q key.
Similarly, there's
also the help function.
It's a similar idea
to the manual page.
But this should just provide a
simpler shorter explanation of--
or help for that specific
function or command.
So if you have specific
questions about a command
or you're like, I don't
know what this command does
or what it's for,
run help on that.
So you saw, ls
hyphen hyphen help.
Another useful one to
check or to use is history.
And history just prints out a
history of all the past commands
we've done.
So you can see this
goes all the way back
to us running nano and
all this stuff before.
So all of our past commands
will show up in the history.
So if I ever need to
reference back to it,
then I can just look at this.
And also, if I ever want
to rerun something or rerun
a past command, I should just
be able to do exclamation point.
And let's say 114, which
was command 114, which
was the ls command.
And then it runs ls.
So if for example, you had a
really long command you ran
and you didn't want to
have to retype all of it,
then you could just quickly
access the history that way
or access that command
that way and rerun it.
You can also just
tap the Up arrow key,
and that'll just scroll
back through your history.
Same thing with Down.
It'll scroll up and down
through your history.
But if you have a
long history, then you
might not want to have
to hunt that far for it.
So that gets us through all
of the functions in that way,
or the functions around file
manipulation and navigation
of the file structure, the
hierarchy within our Linux
environment here.
Another tool or command
that you've seen me run,
though, is the chmod.
So we ran this way--
I think we ran it up here.
Oh, no.
We ran that-- yeah.
We ran this one here,
where we changed
the permissions of this file.
And we actually also ran it
when we were initially trying
to ssh into this ec2 instance.
But to explain a little
bit more about that,
if we just go into
our Documents folder,
I think we had a file in there.
OK.
We created a Contracts folder.
Yeah.
We had a file here.
So let's do ls hyphen l.
Actually make sure
I'm not blocking this.
Yeah.
Ls hyphen l for our test3.txt.
And so you can see now we have
a bunch of different r's, w's.
And there could also
be an x in there.
So what these stand for is
read, write, and execute.
It basically states
whether the user
has access to read that file.
That's, I believe,
the first one here.
So this will be
whether the user has--
this specific user
that we're logged into
has access to read, write, or
execute this specific file.
This test3.txt.
This will reference the group.
So any sort of group-level
permissions that you find.
Whether they are read
or write permissions
or execute permissions.
And this will be
for anybody else.
So other.
Anybody else on this
machine, that's accessing it
but isn't part of this group.
So if we want to change
the permissions of it,
we would do it in this way.
And so chmod is the
command we use to do that.
So for example, we could run,
let's see here. chmod 755.
And then let's do it
for our test3.txt.
And let's look at our
permissions again.
And now, you can see we
have more things listed.
We have a bunch of
r's, wx's, and r's.
And so what this has done is
it set the file to be readable,
writable, and
executable by the owner.
It set it to be
readable and executable
by others either
from the group-level,
so you see r and x
and r and x here.
So by the group and
the others also then
have permissions for this.
You can google all the
different numeric commands,
but to explain like what this
means because again, we did
chmod 755, basically,
the digits themselves
stand for read, write,
execute, or no permissions.
So a 0 is no permissions,
1 is execute permissions,
a 2 is write permissions,
and a 4 is read permissions.
And so what ends up happening is
the first number in that list,
so if we go again here,
this first number, the 7,
is the sum of 4
plus 2 plus 1, which
means that it's
given read, which
was 4 points, 2
points for write,
and then 1 point for execute.
So it's a clever
trick to say, OK.
Well, whatever the
sum of this is,
that'll specify the
level of permissions.
So since the first digit is 7,
that means the owner or sorry.
The user has read, write,
and execute permissions.
This second number
being 5 means that we
are summing the 1 and the 4
because 1 plus 4 gives us 5.
That means we have read
and execute permissions.
If we had done-- oh.
Let's go back here.
If we had made this last digit
of 4, then that would have said,
well, 4 is just
read permissions.
So that would have said, OK.
Well, let's run it really
quick and just show that.
So now you can see that the
owner or the user has read,
write, and execute
permissions, the group has read
and execute permissions.
So that's the sum of 5.
And then the read
permissions only
for others on this computer.
So you'll see this run in
a bunch of different ways.
Remember, when we ran this
just on our ec2 instance or ssh
into our ec2 instance, it said,
you have to run chmod 400,
if you're on a Mac, for example.
On the windows, we
didn't have to do this.
But if you think
about what that means,
is when we did
chmod 400, whatever,
whatever our pem key
was, that set read
permissions for the user account
but only read permissions,
and then 0 for anybody else.
That means nobody
else on that machine,
no matter what user
account they are on
or how they're logged
into that machine,
nobody else has access to read,
write, or execute for that file.
And the user account only
has read permissions.
So that's a way to ensure that
I don't overwrite things or mess
anything up in any way.
So permissions can be very,
very helpful to control, modify,
edit, and all that good stuff.
And that's exactly how we
do it just via that chmod.
We can also change
ownership of a file.
So if we say--
because right now,
this is saying this user
has read, write, and execute
permissions.
If we had another user
on here, though, they
wouldn't be treated--
or their user account,
since let's say,
they were part of
our group, they
would only have read
and execute permissions.
But maybe we're saying,
actually, it's this other--
or this other user's file now.
We want to transfer the
ownership over to them.
So the way we can do
that is we can say, OK.
Well-- and there's not
another user on this account.
So I'm just going to use the
root account as an example.
But what this says now is I want
to move the ownership, change
ownership chown.
I want to change the
ownership from the root
or from who it is right
now to the root account.
So if I rerun this
ls dash l, you'll
see now that instead of it
showing the owner being Ubuntu,
it'll show the owner
as the root account.
Now, Ubuntu user account
happens to also have
root-level permissions.
So that's why we didn't have the
actual permissions themselves
change.
But notice that the
ownership has changed.
Also, to take a
step back, you'll
see me use this
sudo command a lot.
That's not because
it's best practice,
but because of, oftentimes,
what we're doing requires this.
So it stands for super user do.
It basically gives you
root-level permissions
for a specific command.
So to back out and
explain this a little bit,
every user on this
machine-- or think
about your personal computer.
On your personal computer,
you have a user account
that's maybe your name.
You log in to that user
account, and then you
can do whatever you want.
But technically speaking, there
needs to be an admin that has
"complete" ownership
over your computer.
They can do anything and
everything to the computer.
And best practice
would typically
have us not use the
root-level account always
for every little
thing we need to do.
So that's why we don't actually
log in to that admin account.
You sometimes see
this when you go
to install some software,
something like that.
It's like you need
to put in a password
because you need
admin-level permissions
or root-level
permissions to do that.
That's what it's saying.
Is basically we need to
take a step back or ensure
that this person
installing the software
has complete control
of this machine.
And so you have to do
it at the root level.
And that's what we're doing here
with this S-U-D-O, sudo command.
Is we're saying, OK.
For this one command, I'm
running this change ownership.
I want to pretend
for one command
that I am the root user account.
If you do this on
your personal machine,
sometimes, if you have,
for example, a Mac,
you can use sudo
as well, I believe,
you'll be prompted to use a
password or put in a password
when you run that,
because you have
to have complete
ownership of that machine
to be able to do that.
So that's what the sudo
command does there.
And you'll see this,
again, a lot of times
when we have to do
things at a lower level
or at a root level
on the machine.
A couple other
helpful tips here.
We'll clear it out for a second,
so I can see it a little easier.
We have the ps
command, which the ps
command lists all the processes
that are running on our system.
So, for example, if we run--
let's actually go back to our--
not that it matters.
But if I run this now, I
can-- and so I'm sorry.
I just ran ps aux here.
This printed out all of
the processes running here
on my computer.
So every little thing
here that is possibly
running in the background--
you see, most of this stuff
is using 0% of the CPU.
This is all
happening right here.
Or I can actually access
all these individual things.
This can be very helpful, if
you run into a situation where
something is really
freezing up a computer
or is eating up a
lot of resources
and you want to
kill the process.
Then you want to be able
to identify the PID here,
the process ID, and specify it.
And so you can say things like,
for example, if I wanted to,
and I'm not going to
because I'm not running
anything in the background.
So let's say, for example, I
wanted to kill that process,
I would run kill,
and I'm not actually
going to put it in real number.
But let's say I had a process
that was number 6,000.
Then I would run kill 6000.
And that would end that process.
It's like forced quitting
on Macs or like the--
I forget the equivalent
it is on Windows now.
But ending the process or
stopping the process here.
So that's one way to directly
shut down a process that's
running in the background.
Another way to monitor
usage is to run top.
So again, I'll just
show here what I did.
So T-O-P and then hit Enter.
And that'll bring
up a live view.
So this is constantly changing.
You'll see this constantly
change every couple of seconds.
And that'll show
you actively what's
being done on your computer.
So what's using
memory, how much memory
it's using, what percent of
the CPU that's being utilized.
So top can be a
really helpful command
to just keep an
eye on things that
are running in the background.
And then if I want
to back out of top,
then all I need to do
is hit Control and C.
And that'll stop the process.
So that's a way I can
get back to my console.
And Control - C is the go-to
default to shut down something
that's actively running or like
eating up your terminal window
here.
Another helpful tool here.
If you want to see some
of your network details,
like IP address, for example, or
any other network information,
oop.
I have config is not installed.
Let's do IP address.
Is that one installed?
Yeah.
So IP addr.
And we'll show how to install
something in a second.
But I don't want to
do that right now.
And this is your local host.
This is showing your
local IP address.
This 172.
And then it should
show your public,
or might not show
your public as well.
I have to use if config
to show your public.
But either way, you can see
your local IP address here.
This 172.31 and all
that good stuff.
ubuntu@ip.
So you can see it
matches up here.
The .31.29.34.
So that's one way to check that.
If you ever want to check
that your network is connected
to the internet,
or just to see how
the speeds, the
ping to other sites,
you can run ping and then put in
a website name like google.com.
And that'll tell you how long
it takes to ping a website.
If this didn't return
anything or returned an error,
then you might know you have an
internet or a network connection
issue.
So it's just sending
little packets over there
to see, basically,
how long does it
take to communicate
to google.com?
Right now, we're at
pretty consistently
just short of 6 milliseconds.
So again, a helpful tool
to quickly easily access
that information.
From there, we saw
just an example
above where I had a
library or a function
that I-- command that I wanted
to run that was installed.
Another example
like htop is-- oh.
Actually, htop is installed.
So let's do it with ifconfig.
So if I want to install a
package or a function, command,
whatever it is, first off, I
need to know what it's called.
In this case, if you remember,
when we ran ifconfig,
it gave us a hint and said, hey.
I don't think this is installed.
So you should
probably install it.
Way to do that,
relatively simple.
So we're going to
use the sudo again.
The first thing I'm
going to do, though,
is run apt hyphen
get and then update.
And what that does is it's
updating in the background
all of the directories
that have listings
of packages and libraries
that I can install.
You don't have to
run this necessarily,
but it's good practice.
And you'll see me do
this a lot, to say, hey.
Well, I want to
install this library.
Rather than just
trying to install it
and grabbing maybe an
older version of it,
let me make sure I have the most
recent directory stored here
on my computer.
And then I can say, OK.
sudo apt-get ifconfig.
Is it the wrong one?
Oh.
We need to do sudo apt install.
Sorry. sudo apt install.
net-tools first.
So sorry. net-tools.
You can see it up here.
It prompted me to do this.
It's that it's net
tools is the library.
So apt install or
apt hyphen get.
Either one works.
They both will
install libraries.
So sudo apt install net-tools.
And that installed ifconfig.
And now I can run ifconfig to
see all that good information.
Again, as I said before, you are
not expected to know all this.
I am referencing notes
here as I go through this
because I don't remember
all these things
off the top of my head.
So yeah.
Definitely look back at that
and look back at the notes
as we're going through that.
So the final thing I want to
talk about is shell scripts.
So let's clear out
our window again.
So a shell script, it's
a really simple idea.
You've actually-- if you've
done any programming,
you've interacted with
something like this.
Where I want to write a file
down that has a set of commands.
And then I want to be able to
execute those commands just
by running the file.
That's exactly what
a Python program is.
I write some lines in there
that have a specific format.
That specific format is readable
by the Python interpreter.
The Python interpreter says, OK.
Well, when I say,
this, this, this, that
must mean to execute this.
So we write def to
define a function.
And then we use a special syntax
or how we write the function.
And then we make sure
we tab everything in.
And then we write our
function, we return it.
And then if I run that code,
where I execute the function
there, then I actually go
through this line by line
pretty much and
execute the steps.
We can do the same thing really
simply on the command line.
We can do that
with Python scripts
right here on the command line.
But also a common thing to
do is to write shell scripts.
So shell scripts are, again,
just a sequence of commands.
They are listed out in a file.
And then you execute
them all together.
So, for example, you might
have something that says, hey.
Every day I want
you to go in there,
or I want you to go through
and clean out any log
files that have been created.
I can write that as a shell
script and use something called
cron, which you'll get some
experience with in this class
to say, hey.
Every day, run this shell script
that says, open the log files,
remove all the files,
or open this logs folder
and remove all the
files that are in there.
Delete them.
So that way, I cannot overrun
my memory or my storage
or something like that.
So to do that, we just write a--
we can write a script
using our nano.
So nano was the text editor
or one of the text editors
we introduced in
the previous videos.
So let's say-- let's
call this testscript.sh.
So just nano
testscript.sh or whatever
you want to call the file.
And then it's going to open it
up in our text editor window
here.
And then in here,
we're going to write.
We're going to do the little
hash mark and then exclamation
point /bin/bash.
What this is, this says, hey.
This is a bash script.
So you're going to use
the bash interpreter
to execute those commands.
I could have, again, similarly
written a Python function,
where instead I said, hey.
Let's say, I had Python
installed on my computer.
I could have said, OK.
Well, Python is installed here.
So run the commands
that are going
to come below using
the Python interpreter.
And then it's going to use
Python to execute that script.
So that's exactly
what we're saying.
Is we're just saying we have
some sort of interpreter
that needs to execute those.
And this one
specifically we're going
to use bash, which is
super common on pretty
much any Unix-based operating
system or Linux-based operating
system.
And we're going to have this
file just do two things.
First, we're going to have
it print out Hello, world.
And then after that, we
want to print out the date.
This is just special syntax
for our bash scripts here.
So that's why we can
just call it that.
If it was Python,
we'd obviously have
to write that in a
more Pythonic way
or use Python
functions to do that.
So now, we can exit this.
Remember to exit, we
just do Control and X,
and then we say yes to save.
And then we say, yep.
That file name is right.
So control - X. y
for yes, and then
Enter to accept that file name.
So if we look in here now,
we have this testscript.sh.
And then we just need to
do one extra step here
to actually execute it.
We're going to use
our chmod again.
And then we're going to use
the special option here,
plus x, that makes
our script executable.
If we don't do this, then it's
not-- you can see here it just--
or it'll just be
viewed as a text file.
It's not viewed as
an executable file.
So we just have to
tell it to say, hey.
This is executable.
You can run this as a program.
Now, if I do ls, you'll
see it highlights it green.
That's just a special way
of it specifying, hey.
This is some sort
of executable file.
And then finally,
to run that script,
you do dot slash and then
the script name itself.
Dot because we're saying it's
right here in this folder.
And then we're just
saying it's testscript.sh.
And you can see here now.
Hello, world.
And the date when I ran this.
So depending on
when you see this,
maybe this is close
to the date or not.
But either way, that is how
we can run a shell script.
This is a really,
really, really powerful
step to be able to write these
scripts like this that allow us
to go in, and I'll just
cat this test script,
so you can see all
the text again.
Where I can go in and
write a set of commands.
And all I need to do
now is have my commands
or know what the
appropriate command is,
and then I can execute
those tasks just
by writing it as a function.
As I mentioned before, anything
I can do in the AWS console,
I can do on the command line.
There is an AWS
command line interface.
So I can write scripts that
execute all sorts of AWS console
functions just by running
the scripts themselves.
So let's say, again,
every morning I
want to launch my
company's EC2 instances.
And let's say we have
100 EC2 instances.
Rather than having
to go in and manually
click into each
of those instances
and hit Launch Instance, Launch
Instance, Launch Instance,
I can write a bash script
that just says, OK.
For this set of resources,
I want you to launch them.
And I'm going to set it
up using a scheduled job.
And you're going to do
that using something
called cron, which we're not
going to get into cron right
now, but you're going to get
to explore it in a homework.
And cron is basically
a tool for--
and you can see, as the
description says here,
starting tasks automatically.
So I can execute things
based off of time schedules.
So that'll be a
task for you to dig
into some more on your own time.
But for now, we'll
leave it at that.
So that is a whirlwind tour
of the Linux command line.
I know it's a lot.
It's an entirely new way to
interact with a computer,
if you've never done it before.
I have been interacting
with Linux command lines
now probably 10 plus
years, almost 15 years.
And it still is a new
beast to me every time.
But you'll start to learn a
handful of tools and techniques
here.
And it really creates a level
of efficiency in your workflow
that you can't get by using
a graphical interface.
Again, if every time I
want to access a computer,
I have to launch a window or
I have to connect a monitor
and do this.
It's just not necessary.
Oftentimes, all I want to
do is just run a script
or execute a quick command or
change something on my computer.
Or maybe the interface
is freaking out
for whatever reason.
So this is a nice, easy,
clean, lightweight way
to interact with computers.
And will be an invaluable tool.
Again, this is one
of those things
that employers, former
students always come back to us
and tell us, hey.
I wish students knew
more about this.
So this is my way
to say like, we're
going to get a brief
introduction to it now.
You're going to use it
throughout the semester.
And then hopefully, you'll
start to gain some confidence
and can explore it on
your own time as well.
So leave it at that.
And then we'll talk next time.
Dig into some more things
here in the cloud computing.
Thank you.